hola estamos de vuelta para conocer las
principales noticias en materia
económica de américa latina y del resto
del mundo junto a daniela blandón
periodista experta de nuestra redacción
danny vamos a comenzar hablando del foro
económico mundial que está proyectando
que las máquinas van a ser la mitad de
trabajo mundial para el año 2025 esto es
así más como las paredes santiago buenas
noches pues el organismo dice que una de
las consecuencias adicionales de la
pandemia será que en cinco años los
empleadores van a dividir la mitad del
trabajo entre máquinas y humanos pero
así como se prevé la eliminación de unos
85 millones de puestos en al menos 15
industrias también se espera que surjan
97 millones en sectores como la
inteligencia artificial o la creación de
contenidos
robots y los algoritmos se harán el
trabajo de las personas sin embargo eso
no significa que no habrá nuevos
trabajos seguramente surgirán de todo lo
que podamos encontrar en el mundo de los
datos hay nuevas tareas que sólo los
humanos pueden realizar nuevas
habilidades que se necesitarán para
lograrlo
hay una ventaja santiago y es que para
los ahora llamados trabajadores de
primera línea o esenciales podría haber
una presión salarial al alza y la vamos
a méxico porque hay una buena noticia no
el desempleo bajó levemente en este mes
en 621 mil personas se incorporaron de
nuevo a la población laboral activa la
tasa de desempleo que hace un año era
del 38 por ciento en méxico una de las
más bajas de la región quedó en 5,1 por
ciento en el noveno mes de este año si
observamos santiago la tendencia se ve
que antes de la pandemia se mantenía por
debajo del 3% en abril se disparó al 47
y desde entonces ha estado al alza desde
junio descendió levemente y el país ha
venido recuperando poco a poco las
plazas que perdió al inicio de la
pandemia concretamente de las 12
millones de personas que salieron del
mercado laboral en abril 84 millones ya
están de vuelta según el gobierno
continuamos ahora con el polémico abrió
exit que continúa dando de hablar no y
después se van a reanudar en londres las
conversaciones si santiago desde que la
semana pasada el primer ministro
británico
johnson dijo que las conversaciones se
habían acabado inició un intenso lobby
de parte y parte para retomarlas lo más
posible es que reino unido y la unión
europea no se acerquen de a muchos
santiago pero quieren por lo menos
intentar romper por la buena vía una
relación de tantísimos años en lo que no
ha podido ponerse de acuerdo es en el
tema de la pesca y el acceso al mercado
único gran bretaña quiere seguir
disfrutando de las ventajas de entrada a
los 27 países miembros pero para hacerlo
debe dejar que los pescadores del bloque
comunitario sigan accediendo a sus aguas
de escuchamos
el tiempo es muy corto y estamos
dispuestos a negociar las 24 horas del
día los 7 días de la semana sobre todos
los temas basándonos en los textos
legales así que el reino unido tiene una
gran decisión que tomar
pero su respuesta determinará el nivel
de acceso a nuestro mercado interno es
solo sentido común
kamen sense además adora de la
automotriz que es la que va en camino a
un año récord de ventas la fábrica de
autos más grande
de autos eléctricos propiedad del
excéntrico y lo más que superó las
expectativas del mercado y triplicó sus
utilidades en el tercer trimestre hasta
330 millones de dólares y es que a pesar
de la pandemia las ventas de estos autos
de lujo están disparadas santiago le
cuento en apenas tres meses vendió casi
140.000 y este año espera terminar con
al menos medio millón de entregas la
buena noticia es que los precios están
más baratos por si le interesa aunque
eso lo compensa la empresa con sus
acciones cuyo valor se ha quintuplicado
este año bueno estamos para aprovechar
los precios de tesla y que nos dicen los
indicadores de la jornada en eeuu no les
espera la mirada a las negociaciones
sobre un paquete de estímulos que nada
que llega y así se notan la caída de hoy
the wall street' en europa las bolsas
cayeron más del 1 por ciento por las
crecientes restricciones de movilidad
por el avance del coronavirus madrid
tuvo la peor caída en un mes y en
américa latina' todo es en positivo y el
mejor desempeño de la jornada fue para
méxico
para finalizar la siempre esperada cifra
del día son los 170.000 millones de
dólares esta es la fortuna de los tres
empresarios chinos más ricos calculada
para 2020 por la versión china de la
revista forbes
se trata de ya que más el fundador de
alibaba anima de la firma de internet
tencent y tsonga yanchang de la marca de
agua embotelladora no fue un dato
adicional se ha registrado la creación
de riqueza este año más alta que los
cinco anteriores en el habla no gracias
por esta completísima crónica y
económica en nuestra audiencia continúen
informando se en france 24 y en france
24 punto com
[Música]